das internet
gerade mal
aus
[Musik]
hans anton rieder spürt überall wasser
sogar hier auf der spitze des niesen
2362 meter über meer
hier will erbohren sein instrument ist
die route sein beruf wassersuche seine
berufung der welt zu beweisen dass es
überall und für alle genug wasser gibt
seine außergewöhnlichen ideen hat er aus
alten büchern mit hingabe erklärt er
einen geologen seine theorie richtig
wach so ganz sicher die nächte 500 meter
garantie also der dissens problem wir
haben hier also sagen wir also eine
grenze von der situation aber immerhin
das experiment widerspricht jeder
wissenschaftlichen theorie glauben etwas
mache große liebe frau mit wasser war
unter druck stieg demnach auf 1
und vor allem er hat einfach das ist ja
das ist ja das interessante situation
vorher wirklich auf einmal punkte pro
monat muss erwartet dass
einen versuch wert ist allemal haben
sich die betreiber der niesen bahn und
des restaurants hier oben gesagt bis
jetzt wurde das wasser über 700 meter
den berg hinauf gepumpt aber die
bestehende wasserleitung müsste saniert
werden wie iris methode wäre halb so
teuer
darum hat man sich entschieden ihm eine
burgi bild zur verfügung zu stellen
werde behauptet dass man in 60 metern
tiefe auf eine wasserader stoßen wird
[Musik]
das gestein ist zerklüftet die bohrung
deshalb anspruchsvoll
die arbeiten werden dauern
[Musik]
als handlungsreisender in sachen
wasserburg der 66-jährige lötschental
bei privaten auftraggebern und gemeinden
und hat immer etwa 4 bohrstellen
gleichzeitig in thun der bauer anton
cent war ist präsident einer privaten
wassergenossenschaft am sempachersee
seit jahren sind er und seine frau darum
immer wieder mit der gleichen frage
konfrontiert wo findet man gutes wasser
jetzt ist es wieder nötig eine
überbauung ist geplant und ein großer
getränkehersteller sie zu einer
radiosendung hat emily zwimpfer auf den
pendler aufmerksam gemacht vom vorstand
und ich meinen begangen oder das zeigt
aber was möglich und hatte wahllos dafür
längst und sagte die hilfen ist dann die
hans anton rieder pendelt seit 25 jahren
landauf landab und auch im ausland
in dieser zeit hat er seine methode
perfektioniert heute ist er überzeugt
dass er so auf der ganzen welt im
umkreis von 100 metern wasser finden
kann
[Musik]
mit der einen hand router dir
funktioniert folgendermaßen wenn ich mit
dem auge auf die wasser aus der lunge
oder auf zentrum oder anfang an der
wasserburger verlange ich rechtsklick
das geld über das unterbewusstsein
stress darunter nach paris ermordet
da dreht dann nach rechts kann ja mal
fragen der überwältigung von arbeiten
aber der punkt geht nachts zumacht ist
das zentrum wo mich der ufa jetzt in
ihrem zentrum retter wieder nach rechts
und das wirkt das andere und töchter
sein denn das heißt ist aber über 20
meter 20 meter runde jetzt kommt basel
ohne da gibt es die zweite methode dass
ich die so genannte praxis methode die
reagiert wie eine holzhütte waren da
unter wasser ist dann dreht sie einfach
dass die mit einer energie war die
wasserratten abstrahlt dreht sie bei der
firma biotest in zollikofen beurteilt
maria das arbeitsweise mit größter
vorsicht
hans rudolf keusen und seine 25 geologen
bohren regelmäßig für private oder
öffentliche auftraggeber nach wasser
nicht selten werden sie gebeten pendler
bei zu ziehen ist das tor bis dahin
gericht dass die workshop ist spüre die
kreisliga b ist also ganz verschiedene
hatte vor
das ist für mehltau maschine heidi
rüther gut die natur beobachtungsgabe
und intuitive fähigkeit wo wir da sehr
hilft mit einer sage was sie immer
wieder gesehen habe ich das meinen
aufgaben und die
hoppe von wasservorkommen einfach falsch
sie geht der pflege und aus blogs ist
das einfach nur volksmusik wieder
verbreitet weiter vom messer oder trend
praktisch mir bewusst versuchen wir das
erfolgs quote beträgt nach eigenen
angaben in der schweiz etwa 80 prozent
und bei der tiefen messung ist der recht
präzis sagt 20 bis 26
fließt das wasser sich nachdem boris
tadic hat also die qual schwarz halte
geschichte wo das durchfließen und das
ist immer ganz spezielle schicht die
folgt auf der falsche mann über den berg
die geht es anderem see und am see durch
das sieht ja wieder über den berg danach
haben wir uns ist gewachsen hier wurde
man auf der unterseite vom normalen
bohren & villas unter druck ist das
system und das alles hinter raich und
der soll es war nicht der ozeanischen
spezieller warum steht ja auch beim
flirt mit der uws kurven fuß kommen was
der herr trägt das quasi welt umfassen
das wasserrad bestehe und dass die
wasserratten der glotze haben erst
später werden wo der untergrund ihnen
drückt wird die theorie ist absolut
wissenschaft nach unten scheine
undenkbar
das wasser den fahrern sehr projekt das
ist vielen orten der fall aber es wird
wieder normal recke auf der hauptspeise
und ich eine eislauffläche grundwasser
zurück zur bohrung am sempachersee bauer
zwimpfer will sich von re das erfolg
überzeugen
an vier verschiedenen orten wird hier
oben geburt beim ersten bohrloch ist man
wieder vorausgesagt hat bei 121 metern
tiefe auf wasser gestoßen
damit man keine langen leitungen braucht
porträt oder wenn immer möglich in der
nähe eines reservats jetzt will er bauer
zeigen dass er es hier nicht mit
gewöhnlichem grund oder quellwasser zu
tun hat
platz
im bohrloch ist das wasser in der
zwischenzeit um fast 100 meter gestiegen
mit dem licht lot wird es gemessen
nachher mit hochdruck gespürt und wieder
gemessen
warum kann das kein grundwasser seien
[Musik]
für den bauern spielt es keine rolle
hauptsache es ist gutes wasser ganz
wichtig hier denn der boden um den
sempachersee ist überdüngt das wasser
vielfach nitrat verseucht
wasser schmecken da steht mit seiner
theorie über wasseradern ziemlich
alleine da
damit hat er leben gelernt
neues entdeckt oder nicht entdeckt wurde
nicht wo der schule wissenschaft
widerspricht am anfang hat das immer ist
denn so wichtig dass man das alles
bewiesen und selbstverständlich
und wenn ich plötzlich unbeirrt verfolgt
er sein ziel beseelt von der idee der
menschheit doch noch eines tages
beweisen zu können dass es überall genug
wasser gibt als er angefangen hat mit
der pendler haben sie ihn hier im
lötschental für einen spinner gehalten
auf die idee gebracht hat ihn ein
appenzeller pendler
er hat ihm gesagt dass er die fähigkeit
hat dann folgten kurse und jahrelanges
üben
natürlich sieht hans anton rieder führt
ein ziemlich normales leben wenn er
nicht gerade im ausland bord kommt er
wie jeder andere abends nach hause zu
seiner familie tochter ihren und sohn
martin haben ihn nie anders gekannt seit
sie denken können ist ihr vater eben
wasser schmeckt für sie ist das normal
sie sind sich aber vieles gewöhnt und
können von sonderbaren anfragen ein
liedchen singen
großes problem problem
[Musik]
martin war auch schon mit den indien der
vater ist überzeugt sein sohn könne es
ebenso gut
als junger mann das ganze land
problemlos wasser suchen braucht sehr
viel energie und räder macht ja nicht
nur das wie jeder pendler entsteht er
auch wohnungen das braucht noch mehr
kraft und stört hat er auch seine eigene
wohnung denn schlafen auf wasseradern
sei ungesund einen ficus benjamini in
die richtige ecke direkt an beide wände
gestellt löse das problem die pflanze
neutralisiere alle wasseradern im
umkreis von 30 metern behauptet werde
er geht aber noch weiter und sagt es
gebe eine strahlung die noch viel
schädlicher sei den sogenannten
pflanzenwachstums leser bwl 20 durch 20
stockwerk unter einer meterdicken blieb
laut das ist ein raum ist probiert weil
jetzt alle regierungen also da kann man
praktisch nicht abschirmen mit ihren app
ist man kann höchstens verscherbeln
verschob mit dem winkel spricht über zu
verschieben um 250 und außerhalb dem
haus kommen
hans anton rieder auf hausbesuch in
zürich
[Musik]
bei katharina blaß wurde vor zwei jahren
ms multiple sklerose diagnostiziert
seither geht es gesundheitlich auf und
ab wie viele andere ms patienten ist sie
immer auf der suche nach alternativen
heilmethoden weil die schulmedizin noch
wenig hilfe anbieten kann
reda pendelt sie aus weil für ihn der
laser auf dem körper des menschen auch
lesbar ist
beschwerden bekam katharina blass als
sie noch in dieser wohnung lebte zwei
stockwerke tiefer und auf der anderen
seite des hauses also das gleiche
prozedere wird er behauptet alle ms
patienten die er gesehen hat hätten mit
dem untersten wirbel auf einem laser
geschlafen darum vermutet er hier die
ursache der krankheit
hinter lange dass ich weiß mein album
mittel saft mit der diagnose krebs
mittel recht ist katholisch
das ist verschieden aber an der tafel
sind zentrum ich darauf machen vom kopf
problem kommt also zu ende denn weder
das aber da schaut in die analyse ist
klar nur wird sie der patientin wenig
helfen heilen das kann auch hans anton
rieder nicht um seine theorie vom leser
zu belegen hat wie er da von sämtlichen
hausbesuchen protokolle erstellt problem
noch gut entzündet sich an der hüfte
schmerzen in der hüfte
was schon sehr schlecht geht mit leser
zum beispiel ist ja da ich würde sterben
das sind alles so die sache sind wichtig
für mich aber ich habe immer das
langsame studieren das kann ziemlich
schlimm
lisa und wasseradern orten das könne er
auch auf distanz behauptet riether darum
macht er auch ferndiagnosen wir haben
unsere zweifel und lassen ihn einen
wohnungs plan auspendeln der früher
schon von einem anderen pendler auf
wasseradern untersucht worden ist
verblüffend aber zeichnet die adern
genau am gleichen ort auch die letzten
tage haben erfahrung mit ria das
ferndiagnosen wir treffen leute hier die
riaa da schon lange kennen und am anfang
seiner pendler karriere sehr skeptisch
waren mittlerweile aber hat das halbe
lötschental wer das hilfe in anspruch
genommen
ein bauer hatte vier schafe verloren und
schon das ganze tal abgesucht als ihm
jemand den tipp gab räder suchen zu
lassen
situation harmonie mal weg so etwas
machen wir hatten die chance sind sie
die haben gesagt ja probieren
reinhold vom court dann punkte oder die
nähere umgebung war die chancen sie
wirklich verloren und der hans anton
rieder ist schon wieder auf dem sprung
er trifft vorbereitungen für die
geplante indienreise letzte details am
telefon
rajasthan westindien seit fünf jahren
ist ihr kaum mehr regen gefallen
jeder soll im auftrag von hotelplan und
helvetas in zwei wochen zehn bohrlöcher
bestimmen und probebohrungen durchführen
[Musik]
müssen evakuiert
einfach ein mantra tara bringen mir
alles drückt fest die katastrophe viel
zu tun aber eine arbeit die hans anton
rieder fürs leben gern macht
wasserversorgung auf indisch hier von
diesem großen tank aus wird die ganze
gegend versorgt kamele holen das
wertvolle nass und bringen es mit
kleinen tanks zu den zisternen in den
dörfern
mehrere stunden laufen die frauen jeden
tag durch die wüste bis sie bei den
zisternen sind jetzt wo es so wenig
geregnet hat ist der wasservorrat bald
erschöpft
wasser ist in indien ein rares und
teures gut
[Musik]
rea der sucht dort wo die frauen es
wünschen in der nähe der bestehenden
zisternen oder möglichst nahe bei ihren
hütten wenn sie hier wasser finden
würden wären unsere größten probleme
gelöst
es hat 50 höfe hier und wir alle haben
kein wasser
hier soll gebohrt werden
rea da sagt voraus in welcher tiefe das
wasser kommt jetzt wartet man dort auf
die bohrmaschinen währenddessen ist
rihanna schon auf dem weg zum nächsten
dorf
die leute hier haben entschieden dass
sie das wasser gerne neben der kirche
und der zisterne hätten kein problem
in der regel hat slow trainer ja überall
im umkreis von 100 metern wasseradern
der wassermann will ruhe
er muss sich konzentrieren seine
batterien aufladen wie er sagt das
interesse der bevölkerung ist groß die
komischen instrumente faszinieren
zum teil kommen die leute von ganz weit
her um zu schauen was dran ist an der
geschichte vom weißen der in der wüste
wasser findet die verständigung ist eher
schwierig das überlässt er ja da auch
lieber seinem manager roland food ist
für protokoll kontakte organisation von
bohrmaschinen und weisen also für alles
mögliche zuständig mit ihm arbeitet
räder seit ein paar jahren zusammen
hier soll gebohrt werden
nein
[Musik]
80 kilometer weiter hier hat er da vor
drei tagen schon gependelt mittlerweile
haben die bohrarbeiten begonnen
in 48 stunden haben die leute im
schichtbetrieb auf 15 meter herunter
geburt in dieser tiefe sollte das wasser
kommen hat räder prophezeit auch hier
her sind sie aus der ganzen umgebung
gekommen mit leeren händen und voller
hoffnung
dass die frauen ihm ein dankeslied
singen noch bevor das wasser da ist
scheint mir da eher unangenehm
das wasserprojekt in rajasthan wird
mitfinanziert von hotelplan mit dabei
darum auch caspar hees zuständig für die
vergabe von projekten aus dem umwelt
franken mit dem reiseveranstalter hat
wer darauf in südindien schon fünf
brunnen gebaut vier davon mit erfolg mit
marias ist ein großer markt sehr gut der
verein mit seine methode spricht mit
seinen filmen das ist habe kapiert worum
reise die oberfläche oft sehen wir
mehrere postauto unsere projekte
unterstützt das heißt sie macht kabarett
ist ob denn da etwas machen sie keinen
tourismus nimmt viel erwarten und
klassische möglichkeit mit einem lied
will sich aber wenigstens hat und damit
oberster zurück ag scheidet basis
schaffen dass die liebe verrat und
tatsächlich
[Musik]
rea da ist überzeugt dass diese bohrung
viel wasser bringt
neues jahr 2010
was wie ein wunder wirkt ist für die
inder eigentlich schon erklärbar wir
kennen diese theorie mit den wasseradern
sie ist gut in der indischen theologie
ist schon die rede von wasseradern in
der erde und es wird erzählt dass man so
wasser gewinnen kann
aber unsere wissenschaftler sind auch
technokraten sie glauben das einfach
nicht sie sagen es gibt nur grundwasser
und reiter glaubt ja es gibt einen
unterschied zwischen grundwasser unter
wasser
im umkreis von fünf kilometern gibt es
kein wasser
jetzt interessiert es alle ob man dieses
wasser überhaupt trinken kann
sollte
noch ist es sehr salzig das wird sich
auswaschen behauptet werde
und weiter geht's neun von zehn
bohrungen sind erfolgreich eine positive
bilanz zwar bis jetzt aber immer noch
ein tropfen auf den heißen stein
ein anblick der einem in dieser gegend
nicht erspart bleibt der besitzer
erklärt dass die kuh erst vor 3 stunden
gestorben sei verdurstet wie tausende
andere tiere auch am nächsten morgen mit
spannung wird der wassermann erwartet in
diesem dorf hat hans anton rieder vor
einer woche schon geburt mit erfolg
jetzt will er den salzgehalt im bohrloch
kontrollieren
das ist für die leute hier ja
entscheidend mit dem kessel an der
schnur wird der wasserstand gemessen
[Musik]
und der salzgehalt alles unter 1000
milligramm gilt in dieser gegend als
trinkwasser in indien trinkt man wasser
mit relativ hohen salzgehalt ihnen
schmeckt sogar nur 100 meter entfernt
gibt es einen alten brunnen warum
braucht es denn überhaupt einen 95
problematik dass da sehr stark für sich
im umkreis von zwölf kilometern sind
alle brunnen versalzen
immer wieder taucht die frage auf können
wir das nicht selbst aber nur die
wenigsten getrauen sich die route
überhaupt in die hand zu nehmen
es gibt bei uns auch leute die das
können
allerdings suchen die grundwasser jetzt
wollen wir diesen leuten auch workshops
anbieten um sie weiterzubilden damit sie
auf wasseradern spüren können
zehn der menschen so glaubt räder können
das wasser im boden spüren
das junge mädchen scheint talent zu
haben und ob der wassermann aus dem
letzten teil wirklich nicht taugt als
lehrer
[Musik]
zurück in der schweiz
in zollikofen bei geologe keussen von
ria dass theorie über die wasseradern
hält hans rudolf keusen immer noch
nichts aber eine schlüssige erklärung
für die erfolgreichen bohrungen in
indien hat er auch nicht und konnten wie
sie der täter wurde da und nachspürt
suppen user das natürlich das wo es auf
die leute waren sehen
gesetzlich hätte vielleicht nicht die
unverfrorenheit sagte airport oder de
groot wird sehr schnell an studierende
jetzt geologie über das synagoge wird
literatur studieren und so um und wird
der verursacher wurde da in einem gebiet
machen
die organisation für freiheit was
überhaupt zentrierte kritisiert wie
unverfroren hätte fraport zum ausgleich
realer und reporter wonach die
wirtschaft und das schadet usa
geschaffen
ein weiterer unterschied noch der
letzten thaler ist um einiges billiger
das 13 erkennen dass er das schottern
also für die lead natürlicher bomben von
cacau das ist das ganz klar das klingt
so vor guten apple muss nur dass das
wahr sein opa in radauti das ist eben
das problem und nachher wie lanxess
nutzbar ist
mindestens teilweise
immerhin führen neun von zehn
bohrlöchern im moment wasser und überall
ist das wasser trinkbar bestätigt man
uns nach einem halben jahr aus indien
eine woche später bei georg fischer in
schaffhausen ihres erfolg in indien
zeigt wirkung gfm rohrleitungs bereich
tätig will einsteigen offerierte hat
sich etwas verändert er kommt mit einem
neuen manager kommunikationsberater hans
peter bühler wer ihr das vision von der
blühenden wüste groß vermarkten sagt
oder mit
mit dem wasser vorkommen wenn er schätzt
dass er 180 m2 backpulver und bewerbung
war es arbeite ich jetzt noch die ca
ich suche erwachse übers wasser
also herr i7 höchste mir sind ja ein
hightech konzern also mehr mehr mehr
mehr mehr graubart wissenschaft aber wir
sind
das funktioniert
das ist keine computer die möglichkeit
das absurd wenn das was da ich jetzt
nicht wird doch nicht alle so man eben
nicht da
euro
im zentrum der finanzkrise
jetzt findet sie immer was ja schon mal
fällt aber den richter hat zum letzten
mal 100 prozent grund das problem ja ich
muss natürlich auch vor ort sehe aber
wenn ich glaube grundsätzlich karriere
wenn das heißt die hundert prozent aber
das würde vertragsbasis mit ihnen machen
es ist es so wir haben natürlich immer
kleinere projekte machen wir niemals
auch unter meiner mal alles für 230
schweizer franken gemacht und ich gehe
meinen in der größenordnung - dem rausch
starten
die details müssen noch verhandelt
werden hans anton rieder fährt wieder zu
bauer zwar an dem sempachersee jede
seiner bohrungen zieht sich über monate
hin und immer kann ganz viel dazwischen
kommt bauer hat in der zwischenzeit die
laborwerte bekommen
zusammen mit geologe keussen wartet er
auf den mann aus dem letzten teil
boston hat für das gemüse das studium
der neuesten laborwerte geologe keusen
ist beeindruckt war zwar im glück wäre
hat in dieser schwierigen gegend in mehr
als 100 metern tiefe offenbar
trinkwasser gefunden
bleibt die frage nach der menge bei zwei
der vier bohrlöcher wurden pumpen
installiert und punkt versuche
durchgeführt
jetzt will jeder kontrollieren statt der
erwarteten 120 liter pro minute
er gibt der pumpversuch im moment aber
nur gerade etwa 80 immerhin als man vor
ein paar jahren nämlich hier nach wasser
suchte hat man nur gerade drei meter
befinden
gemeindeammann am rhein hat in den
letzten sechs wochen zweimal am tag die
wassermenge genau gemessen und akribisch
buch geführt
unbekümmert wasser so verfügen sie
konsumieren so besser behaupten
neuerdings lässt rihanna seine arbeit
genauestens dokumentieren
seit sich kommunikationsfachmann bühler
eingeschaltet hat läuft eben
professionell besser vermarkten heißt
das motto
das ist das ist zu wenig an die
öffentlichkeit und das muss einfach mein
service software entwickler muss großen
sogar muss man bald die ganze muss man
aber dass fußball und ich sehe also
zukunftsmusik sei nicht auch so dass in
jedem land wo die hersteller sind das
nicht das separat die organisation ist
nur dass dort wuschen
reich geworden ist er bisher übrigens
nicht mit seiner vision und auf dem
niesen ist die bohrung ins stocken
geraten erst bei 52 metern sind die
vorleute auf fels gestoßen die spitze
des niesen ist also nichts anderes als
ein haufen von geröll bei 64 metern
kommt immer noch kein wasser kein
material keine luft trier da kann es
kaum glauben
beim ausbauen dann die überraschung
immerhin die letzten zwei stangen sind
nass
mit spannung wird fertig ausgebaut jetzt
will jeder wissen ob es dort unten
wirklich das erhoffte wasser gibt der
test mit der schnur
zuerst muss man herausfinden ob man noch
auf 64 meter herunter kommt oder ob das
bohrloch schon wieder verstopft ist
dann nochmals ein erfolgserlebnis
die kleinen erfolge nützen nichts
um weiter zu bohren müsste man wegen dem
zerklüfteten gestein nochmal 40000
franken investieren
zu viel findet der auftraggeber wie geht
ihr damit solchen tiefschlägen um
natürlich mit meiner theorie alleinige
sagen ja wie gesagt dass das nicht geht
obwohl das das hundertmal gegangen ich
habe das spiel den erfolg aber dass ich
meine ich das möchte stark belastet das
geht auch nach dem frust am niesen geht
schnell bis ein neues projekt angerissen
ist bei der bohrfirma mit der reeder
seit jahren dort laufen schon wieder
vorbereitungen in arosa auf dem
weisshorn soll erbohren also wieder auf
über 2500 metern theorie von der masse
anderer bestätigt das beste projekt
meine in der beziehung für eine
winterlinde junior kloster hat seit
zwölf jahren erfahrung mit rihanna ihr
schätzt seine erfolgsquote auf zwischen
70 und 80 prozent
es ist immer wieder phänomenal wenn man
natürlich möglich europa sind also
center meisten bergbahnen und die
doppelte und und auch ist jetzt spinnen
downloaden und es funktioniert irgendwie
woher nimmt der mann die kraft immer
wieder neu anzufangen immer wieder
projekte anzureißen die antwort finden
wir im lötschental ihr vor hans anton
rieder als junge jeden sommer als
geistert durchs tal gezogen ist ein
guter geist sei eben auch ein guter
wassersuche behauptet er und wasser
suchen das bedeutet ihm alles geht
einfach sind ein tropfen auf heiße
steine nicht alles machen und wann die
trends für die er mit dem wasser so auch
etwas werden am wichtigsten wäre das
wichtig waren jetzt hier gelten würden
so investieren
bohrmaschine